foreign
[Music]
so on most days I start my practice
session off with a warm-up but in
general a lot of times I don't think of
how I'm going to end a practice session
so today I thought I would come up with
a few ideas that I could use as worn
Downs or cool Downs however you want to
call them so all of these I want to
focus on keeping everything very loose
and relaxed and not doing any sort of
strenuous or tension filled exercise
just kidding
so this first one involves just a five
note chord any five note chord I'm just
going to choose this one
so what I'm going to be doing at first
is pull down all five notes
these two or three notes at a time
and then restrike those notes that I
just released
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
and so forth
with the left hand as well
[Music]
this next one is just with Major Seventh
chords in both hands and one hand is
going to go up by chromatic steps
and the other
[Music]
we'll do this zigzag
[Music]
type motion
[Music]
so what I'm doing this I'm trying to
exaggerate this upwards roll movement
which is led by the elbows and my wrists
are very relaxed and loose
so by the time I'm releasing the note
I'm very relaxed and
yeah I'm just very relaxed
[Music]
foreign foreign
I can switch this so that my right hand
is going up by chromatic steps and my
left hand is
doing that pattern
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
this next one is just a figure that I
came up with
and I like the sound of it when it's
transposed up by minor thirds
so I'm just going to do that while again
exaggerating this upwards roll motion so
that my hands are nice and loose by the
time I release the nuts
thank you
I can do this backwards
[Music]
and because they're going up by Meyer
thirds
there are two more sets starting from d
flat and D
so like I said before I don't really
think about how I'm ending my practice
sessions but I do like to end a lot of
them with a little bit of improvisation
so in the next video I'd like to show
you some things that I do with chords
and
um several things that I do to come up
with new ideas for different sounds that
I like
[Music]
so anyway look out for that and I'll see
you in the next video bye
[Music]
thank you
[Music]